I was really nervous I want to talk
about the bronze the fact that you
starting this you've co-wrote this with
your husband and we're in the story palm
from the idea first came my husband and
I went back to my very small town in New
Jersey after I started having just a
tiny bit of success on TV I was working
on this talking head show and we went
back to the local mall and the manager
at the store recognized me and he gave
me a free Wetzel's pretzel and I was so
excited my husband and I like sat there
eating the pretzel like it was the
best-tasting thing in the world and then
a few months later the show was
cancelled and I went back to the mall
and the manager pretended like he didn't
know me he charged me full price for the
pretzel so we started talking about
celebrity in a small town and what that
would do and then we sort of combined it
with the world of gymnastics and the
idea that bronze metal was always
something that we're huge gymnastics and
Olympics fans and we were watching the
games we always thought it was so funny
that when the announcer would say
they'll have to settle for the broad
your character is very different you go
out there and literally almost every
line that you say should have a beep
over your mouth I think we rival
Scarface
compared to this character I'm a real
[ __ ] can I say [ __ ] it's so fun to
play this character who doesn't give a
crap what people think and it's sort of
bled into my lane personally sebastian
stan is in this movie you guys have some
great teams together but there's one
scene in particularly it's a very sexy
gymnastics Exene but how awkward is that
where fun is that to write something
like that you're like yeah I'm gonna do
that and you're just gonna have to hang
out he was such a good sport about it
and obviously it was also partly his
brainchild but there was when Sebastian
was he
really he goes for it you see a lot a
lot of sebastian stan in this movie many
sides to him like all the women were
sort of gathered around model or mother
like we were trying to catch a bridal
bouquet of the sebastian stan i mean i
think every guy would be excited if they
were described as about the weekly wager
are you are you familiar with what
happens every week on the box office
tiffany has not done it well this year
no here's my problem when we interview
actors who are in the movies or chatting
with them i feel bad
picking a low number so that's really
sweet i'm thinking about their feelings
what adults from a good place
comes from failure okay last week we bet
on London has fallen
Tiffany fat twenty six five twenty one
point six which means this week's loser
should comes from youtube user Mario a
who writes loser should meow every time
the word movie is said it's just so
great to be here with people who enjoy
movies as much as I like movies
this is so good we can make a movie
about what it's about psyched about it
and want to go see it how do you feel
about this one I want to see it I'm
excited about okay so I think it looks
like a good movie I'm gonna make 20
million hmm last time you bet 26 it
didn't work out that well the last time
I bet 25 it did so 25 if you guys have
things you want them to do use the
hashtag Boozer should in the YouTube
comments below on Facebook and on
Twitter I can't even think of a creative
way ELISA and bronze obviously has
sports in the film
what about gymnastics that really made
you guys say yeah we want to do
gymnastics my husband I have always
loved that world and also I'm under five
feet tall so it's not like I was gonna
play a WNBA player that was I like I'm a
huge hockey fan when we were trying to
get this film made actually we met with
some producers who had said that they
wanted to make it but and they could get
more money for it if they put another
actress in the role and we sort of held
on to it we kept on calling this my
rocky yeah and I actually saw Stallone
at a party recently I was very awkward
to readers like I just want to tell you
that and he was so nice like you would
have you would have run with your whole
life smells like a champion I can tie
that into the movie I don't think about
because bill Conti did the score for
Rocky you also do the score for the
Karate Kid talking about competition
talk about being the underdog and going
against the odds daniel-san certainly
did that
this year looking at the films that have
come out we've had a couple of sports
films where you talk about anything
eagle that of course we had race that
came out and Creed I mean I think that
Creed is amazing you talk about man who
smells like a champion all right
speaking of winning and losing
you had a chance to win or lose against
our guests today okay it is time for
king now before we start this game I'm
gonna let you off the hook it's gonna
annoy me fair you said the name of our
show which has that word in it so okay
now it's done
the first round pretty simple you have
to try to catch three pieces of popcorn
in your mouth first person to get three
just throwing in round two this is
called tagging I'm going to read a
tagline from a movie about sports you
guys will buzz in and guess what movie
one dream for Jamaicans 20 he taught him
the secret to karate lies in the mind
and heart
correct his whole life was a million one
shot oh I know this whole life was a
million to one because I don't like
Tiffany win it I need you to look
straight into the camera
if you move your face away from the
camera even look that you lose straight
and today This Is It this is a surprise
round what are the three movie posters
behind me right now I have no idea
come on come well London London is
falling Zootopia
wait I'm getting on hold on it's coming
to me coming to me hold on crap oh crap
I mean it's Oh Oh 10 Cloverfield Lane
tiffani still wins it was fun thank you
so much Melissa for joining us thank you
and you guys can check out her movie the
bronze in theaters on March 18th and
make sure you follow her on twitter at
melissa rauch instagram @v melissa rauch
and follow the movie on twitter as well
at the bronze movie if you want to check
out more episodes of movie three so make
sure you click Subscribe right up there
and then check out past episodes right
over here and then make sure that you
download the Fandango movie clips app on
your smart phone join us every week here
on